I've heard from a couple different sources though the benefit of a 21-day water
fast for treating cancer. In one case I heard a tumor shrinkage about 50%
within the 21 days. That was a colorectal tumor which is similar to what I
have. I have also heard lower back pain from a prostate tumor going away
completely within three days. Do you have comments on the value of a full
water fast treatment for cancer symptoms? Well, I think we just addressed this
question this last week too, that there's a plenty of evidence that doing
fast over 24 hours increases in IGF1 levels which is a growth hormone factor
which that's why most people don't recommend doing more than a 24-hour fast
for cancer patients because it will increase IGF1 levels. But I have had
patients that have done a 10-day fast, a 7-day fast, a 21-day fast, and even a 40-day
fast and it really helped them. The only thing you have to really be careful of
is the second half of this question. I am a 10-year-old person 615 pounds. That's
pretty tiny. If you're doing a 21-day fast, you're definitely going to lose
weight. I mean, definitely going to lose weight. And one of the worst things for
a cancer patient is to fall into the trap of Cakesia, meaning that, oh my gosh, I'm
down to 135 pounds and now I can't even put on weight. That is that can be a
really bad thing for a cancer patient. That could be a tumble that you can't get
on. So if you're thinking of trying a longer fast, whether it be three days, five
days, seven days, ten days, or even something like this, I would say, don't try it
unless you have some weight to lose. So, oh boy, I could lose 20 pounds and I
would still be, you know, not be too thin. Well, then that can be something that you
could pray about and try. Not against trying things that maybe go against some of
the research out there. Hey, the research isn't perfect either. If you feel like
God's leading you to something, try it. But you also got to be wise. And if you're at,
you know, weight like this, I don't know that that's a wise thing to do. I would
say that that would be my first go too.